[Music]
hey guys have you heard that deke News
has a podcast you could check out the
links in the description and then once
you're listening on your way to work or
on the bus or whatever make sure to rate
us what if they don't have a job I don't
know then they can be going to school
they don't have money and they don't
have phone or technology how are they
watching us I had no idea they use your
friends
not everyone has technology tip yeah
come on then you can steal don't forget
to write it though cuz that helps a lot
the links down in the description box
below baby good deeds are gone wrong
news I feel like that would happen to
David yeah that's about right have I
hurt myself in dancing absolutely I
didn't stretch before dancing on stage
and I was hosting a dance event and then
I started dancing was with URI and then
I danced a little too aggressively and
jumped and I hurt my [ __ ] balls it's
cuz he didn't French made the stretcher
chode if you stretch then you don't I
never pulled my chode before you never
like how to pee really [ __ ] bad and
then like you go pee and then that whole
area was tense the whole time cuz you're
holding in your pee and then you [ __ ]
crap your chode no no never it's never
happened that's not right my brother's a
doctor he says that's not possible
your brother's a doctor your brother's a
doctor the Air Force doctor that's right
barb don't say one who's air Trevor
drool after a bar patron who was
accidentally shot by a breakdancing FBI
agent is getting free drinks for life
breakdancing happy hey breakdancing FBI
I can't wait for the free drinks for
life this story is the best story I've
ever heard on JK this [ __ ] that's
incredible a breakdancing FBI agent was
he an undercover breakdancers was
off-duty Oh Doody I'm sure he was
[ __ ] break dancing with his belt on
like the Gumba oh I wish she was because
that's funny they always like a
concealed one FBI don't wear gun belts
what do you mean they don't want come
back we're gonna bail they do
agent yeah I was sure I was curious
there's out of curiosity I always try to
prove you wrong you called me out you
never give my pants down
you didn't say nice try once again who's
our friend you said no wait doll I don't
know we don't did you're making up words
you do surprised that you did you were
good enough you would have continued off
of what he said is dead you freaked out
talk I did did you wanna say yeah we met
him at that party remember
oh yeah that guy's memory suck like I
thought you were my [ __ ] dude - go -
you can't rob a baby cuz you don't know
that cops are not FBI
that's big they always wear the blue
coat think of Mulder do you'll start
crying right now just start crying there
you go Mulder and Scully that's FBI if
you did you think you made your wife cry
that's right they were soon and good
investigate aliens don't you know that's
what my brother cries or is it one of
the ones that they have like on the side
yes always it's always that [ __ ] right
how's it go with a nice leather leather
holsters did you go mmm
like if it's food no I went mm-hmm like
she was picturing Jean Anam yeah I would
never use leather holsters that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks man for guns scheana has
gun holsters they're fake no they're
like was like wallet holsters Oh for
like ps3 controller don't think it's
control my gonna use today not the video
oh the FBI unique are they dancing on
actual turf yeah inside the building
they're not there to boy
that doesn't in Denver okay here we go
doctors in Denver heard about FBI agent
somebody though he puts it back he
smiles I didn't do this a big shot he
shot someone he goes here's a shot he's
definitely a TI agent so he wasn't even
like oh are you okay I don't think he
noticed so what happened to the person
so the dude got shot in the leg oh my
god he's fine he's good and so but he's
still recuperating in the hospital
of course this person get fired from the
fob ah
so for some time they were investigating
but now it's come out that he's being
held and he's facing second-degree
assault charges why is this fool doing
that looks with the gun he got too
excited
was it loaded yeah like you just picked
it up and it went off on safety he went
into a bar with a loaded gun which is
against the board's rules is what the
wine was the Bureau frowns on it the FBI
agent that it's in common yeah he was
off-duty so then they're looking into
like an FBI agents that are off-duty
even carry a gun I think they can t make
any I can I mean they can air marshals
to the they were there they have it all
the time yeah def different Rudy police
officers can yeah so then they're saying
that now he's been arrested he's 29
years old as he was change all that
sucks though yeah he was actually in
Denver for training so he's not like a
fool I know he wasn't even like oh you
know you are you are an agent and then
he trained right something like that
cool yeah he looks like one of those FBI
guys that works at court like the office
what's his name change he doesn't look
like a field agent like no he looks like
that show the new the new show with
everyone's watching them with FBI it's
like Criminal Minds or whatever
Netflix he looks like he could be one of
the employees at the office yeah he
looks like a regular dude yeah pull the
Dwight Schrute dude yeah it's crazy yeah
he doesn't look like one of those guys
that takes down the mob no that's too oh
you know mine hundred that's what I was
thinking mine huh
he looks like that my god and why did he
pick up the gun by the tree when there's
a gun in your waist you got too excited
it's a gun like that it doesn't get hot
after you shot you put it back in no I
was just was just wandering far away
after add the gun by the trigger and
then he pulled the trigger
yeah well he's still in training I think
it went off when it fell no it did it no
yeah he picked up any qualify the
trigger plate again oh so he pulled it
yes he was picking it up because it fell
flat okay sick moves this is where the
sickness okay move yeah all he's still
in it he got a little too excited wising
oh the BA all he had in his back pocket
laughs okay he picked it up he picked it
up and pulled the trigger
what if he did that on purpose we just
did everyone and there's an actual
target that he was trying to assassinate
and anyone shot this is like out of a
comedy movie yeah no I didn't think like
[ __ ] like this happen in real life that
could be like Channing Tatum in like 21
Jump Street yeah and it gets a laugh and
then it cuts to the next scene I can't
believe he didn't freak out he just like
alright guys [ __ ] bullet went there
must have been people screaming and then
like if someone's like wow he's just
like hey that's your fault for standing
there it's such a cop past thing to do
dang if you just picked up his gun by
the handle it would in everything that's
what he's supposed to do it's called
should not pick it up by the [ __ ]
handle do it like this he goes okay cool
[Laughter]
did he already dodged the bullet by it
falling and then not like most people
that train they pick it up like this
you're not supposed to pick it up with
your finger in you know you're looking
at trigger safety bug trigger control
bar
and to see like there was alcohol in his
system because this was like early hours
you can't dance that good without
alcohol you can't get that rubbery
without alcohol yeah you saw losses but
he's moving like a [ __ ] car wash that
it's like advertisement thing I didn't
see any breakdancing happening though I
think they they [ __ ] up with that yeah
he was a breakdancing oh my god you've
got I saw him waving they should rename
the title that story yeah you should
have be called wish it should be called
white guy dancing yeah yeah and he does
a black a black foot I'm sorry I could
see The Rock Steady Crew just watching
this like yeah piss yeah and
breakdancing [ __ ] Run DMC's watching
this shit's like that's not breakdancing
yeah exactly a lot of people are like
what the hell you're mad about the not
breakdancing right what do you think
you're doing that's why the guys
pressing charges cuz use honey in pista
he got shot because it went through yeah
he's pissed about the breakdancing yeah
how dare you yeah it's kind of cool I
mean at least that guy got shot they
survived it's a cool story to tell
yeah and the bar that he's gonna get
free drinks for life oh yeah that's
great but it's gonna get sued through
his head or its [ __ ] heart or some
[ __ ] or like oh man he died what's is
long as medical gills bills get paid a
little rubbery right now yeah a lot of
my medical bills get paid and I get free
drinks nobody's being sued I want to
talk to this bar in this guy year - okay
how's free drinks for life going like
this guy like you open a bar guy and you
like hey how sweet cheeks all talk to me
strolling out a free tricks for life car
your fault you're kidding me already
don't like to have a drink to the year
like that kind of [ __ ] yeah you sits
there and drinks all day yeah breakfast
lunch dinner life goes downhill and his
free drinks count for his lady or if he
brings his family in come on yeah that's
all your share I want to know the
legalese of all cuz I just take a sip of
the beer and then pass it off to my
friend and get another firewood - that's
some [ __ ] loophole [ __ ] that's like
Souplantation loophole yeah
no no my friends just eating this is
gonna hang out with me yeah no [ __ ]
feed him a radish oh yeah feel like
taking salad there have been a soup I
tasted pages
[Music]